i'm here with a dear old friend and the
incredibly charming scott speedman
oh speedman i'm so happy for you i
really am i love when you call me
speedman it's great i love it i've only
ever called you speed might not only
will ever call you speed mean even oh i
love it now that you're about to be a
dad at any moment i'm just at any moment
so happy for you and lindsay really i
mean we knew each other when we were
kids and we're
being grown ups now and i don't think it
ever feels like being a grown-up but i
don't know what that what that sensation
is but it i'm glad we're at this time in
our lives and that everything
that you're just killing it out there
you know with your career and parenthood
just doing all the things speedmen i'm
trying to do all the things trying to be
an adult we'll see how it goes well part
of doing all the things and being an
adult and being in our jobs is being on
social media
yes well i would love to personally get
involved um in your social media game i
wanna i'm all up in your biz speedman in
a segment we're calling drew it for the
gram
oh no
sounds terrible
[Applause]
right for every good social media
account it needs a good throwback
thursday so i used those two pictures uh
that i personally took
um of you in the first segment let's
bring up uh you and justin this would be
a great one to do under hashtag
throwback thursday everybody loves a
throwback yes tvt i got you
wonderful
yeah i'm getting it i'm getting it well
the other one as i spoke to martha
stewart about personally and she taught
me all about a thirst trap
that would be a thirst trap
is it i don't think that's a thirst trap
i don't know what that is but not a
thirst trap that's like a disorientated
human that's probably inebriated in the
middle of a party with his underpants
okay lastly it always helps to have a
picture with an influencer that will
literally boost your numbers like
nobody's business influencers are quite
powerful people such as
someone that we have here
she has over 1.1 million instagram
followers and over 1.6 million tick tock
followers please look at one of her most
famous videos right here i had so many
cute outfits planned for this year that
i couldn't wear so i just wanted to show
you see this i love it i couldn't wear
it love it couldn't wear it then there's
this love it couldn't wear it love it
couldn't wear it and this was supposed
to be my cute costume but no
please say hello to the one and the only
the original she's so hot she actually
has imitators it's tikka the iggy
she is a phenomenon
okay she really really is i mean i'm
star struck i really am
and she liked me she she gave me a big
lick earlier which was really okay
and
if you would like we'd all like to take
a picture with you speedman and tikka
and um i'm telling you it's gonna
up that up the game a bit up that game
because tikka has game all right so here
we go we're gonna lean in i'm gonna i'm
gonna come closer to you
okay
and then we'll look forward
we'll say tikka on three ready one two
three tikka
[Laughter]
great
thanks tika i appreciate it um i i will
make sure to get a special message and
some words of wisdom from tikka to send
to you but mostly i'm probably going to
send you um some gear that i discovered
along the way
of being a parent
that absolutely was essential
and i know you speedmen i feel like
you're going to want to travel light and
like i'm going to get you some light
gear
because
you yes exactly i'm going to get you
some light
nimble gear
okay because parents can get really
overloaded like just going to the
grocery store you feel like you're you
know packing up a u-haul and it's not
okay these are the things i don't know i
don't know what i don't know that's the
thing here i don't know what i don't
know well i think we all know this we
love scott speedmen
well right back there thank you
good to see you so happy for you
sweetheart i really am season 18 of
grey's anatomy airs thursday at 9 8
central on abc and be sure to check out
the new season of you streaming now on
netflix love you speedman we'll be right
back
[Music]
you